i'm going balls on the top dick on
bottom baby it's like a [ __ ] mullet
for your [ __ ] why not right
[Music]
today's episode i answered the
internet's brought to you by showtime
stick around to the end to find out
details on how to order the jay paul
fight what's up i'm trevor wallace and
today i'm gonna answer the internet i
hate the internet what's up i'm trevor
wallace aka whiteclaw douchebag and
today i'm gonna answer the internet
what's up i'm trevor wallace and today
i'm gonna face my biggest fear and
answer the internet what's up i'm trevor
wallace your favorite [ __ ] boy and today
i'm gonna answer the internet would you
rather date a nine with a really
annoying voice or a four with the
sexiest voice ever
four baby fours all day call me john
daly because i'm getting the goddamn
fours baby why wouldn't you want a four
with a sexy ass voice then when you're
out of town the phone sex is just
amazing you just you're picturing pam
anderson but she's over there like hey
daddy how was your show tonight and
you're like this is amazing because if
you're dating the nine she's like that
was your show tonight and you're like is
this [ __ ] chuck liddell on the phone
who am i talking to i'm going fours all
day baby fours
get
divorced i don't know four's force horse
king's cup we've all been there if you
were getting a haircut from a nine i
think there's a theme here if you were
getting a haircut from a nine and you
two hit it off and exchange numbers but
she gave you the shittiest haircut would
you still call her yeah i'm just getting
a new [ __ ] barber all right why
wouldn't i still call her like hey
you're great let's go on a date also
don't ever touch my hair again okay i'll
go to sports clips after this [ __ ] is
sports clip's the one or is it great
clips anything that says clips at the
end is a shitty place to get a haircut
if you have to say in the name what you
guys do ay we do it eclipse trash leave
the clips to the clippers because they
can barely even do that are they good i
don't watch sports anyways
i'm calling her all right because men
we're just horny we'll call anybody all
right that's like the worst caveat ever
it's like ah but you can't give you a
haircut i don't give a [ __ ]
send her in would you give up sex to be
able to dunk no what am i gonna what am
i gonna do with the ability to dunk
because that's why guys think they can
dunk i once had a friend in high school
who bought shoes that allegedly made him
jump two inches higher shout out my boy
cj he would be named cj then he dunked
and then he didn't get any [ __ ] so
what's the point if you can dunk but
you're not gonna get any kuchi all right
i've put a sticker on a backboard before
that made me feel good that made me feel
like i got at least played d3 at like
iowa or something made me feel good for
ten thousand dollars would you spend two
days carrying around a human japanese
robot that you had to introduce to
people as your girlfriend i'm assuming
that's a sex robot because if it was a
normal robot i'd be like hey this is
irobot the star of so now give us a
table at mastros okay because this is
the irobot yeah ten thousand dollars i
mean dude i would do a lot of things for
ten thousand dollars i would bring her
to a wedding for less than that you know
what's great about this absolutely
everything because then people are like
i think he's on some elon musk [ __ ] he's
probably got the future he can probably
microchip us if we say no you're right
this way sir we got you to a booth right
here would you date a hot chick who
cheers for your rival team yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] about sports i'm not good
i'm not athletic who gives a [ __ ]
alright even if i'm like a philly guy
and she's like a new york guy is there
beef there i don't know would you rather
fight a short gladiator or a rhino
i'm gonna go short gladiator cause i
don't even have to fight him i can just
make five three jokes all day like
what's up dude what's it like not being
able to reach the brown sugar on the top
shelf and then he just puts his armor
down he's like you know what man [ __ ]
you and then he turned into the bagel
boss guy remember actually bagel boss
guy was very angry i might go back to
rhino okay i'm nervous short people do
have that short people energy where
they'll swing but they'll hit you in the
kneecap but it's like it's like a stiff
one so you just hit your leg on the
tabletop
but yeah i'm going short people because
rhinos
i don't know rhinos are too intimidating
because that's the number one animal
they put on like sex like boner pills so
there's just a lot to comprehend there
when it's like running at you and you're
like god this reminds me of an erection
then everybody's like what did you just
say and you're like bring out the
gladiators just bring them out
would you rather have your dick and
balls located on your taint or have them
where they normally are but with balls
on top
on top
okay
i have a seventh grade reading level
it's a true story when i was a sophomore
in college my mom thought that i was a
little uh slower than most people at the
university it was a state school so
already off to a terrible start she made
me go get tested at school to see if i
fit to be like hey can i take longer on
the exams and they're like no you're
fine there's nothing wrong with you
usually at the seventh grade level so
thanks for humbling me mom and now i
will attempt to read what this says
would you rather have your dick and
balls located on your taint that's the
under part or have them where they
normally are but with balls on top balls
on top and dick on the bottom i'm going
balls on the top dick on bottom baby
it's like a [ __ ] mullet for your [ __ ]
why not right and then it kind of droops
down looks like an elephant you know
elephants have big snouts aka makes me
look much bigger call me elephant [ __ ]
or not you could call me trevor if you
want doesn't really matter would you
[ __ ] a porn star already have
i'm just wait what did that say
would you [ __ ] a porn star if afterwards
she had to hold a press conference on
your performance yeah i mean why
do you think it's going to be good she
[ __ ] guys that are 7-3 for a living
right the last guy she slept with just
had a pool noodle for a dick what like
what am i
it's gonna be the saddest press
conference ever sweet guys so what was
it like when he put in that minute 47 to
work and she goes uh
i wish it didn't happen and you go well
it barely did it's like six vines in a
row if you think about it so i don't
know if you guys are noticing there's a
common theme of just horniness from most
men on the show it's like we'll do
anything i don't have to read the card
i'm already gonna say yes whatever this
is
would you rather get your girlfriend
pregnant never mind would you rather get
your girlfriend pregnant when you're 16
or get your wife pregnant when you're
60. i'm going 60 right that'd be awesome
being 60 and you got a kid
and the [ __ ] baby goes to suck on a
tit and it's just like kahlua or just
some shitty alcoholic stuff would you
rather be able to have sex with any five
people for a year or get to power womb
what does that mean power is that
getting fisted uh power womb whoever you
want whenever you want for a year i
don't know what
powerbomb guys what did i say about the
whole seventh grade reading level here
when was last time anybody actually read
ask yourselves that we're coming out of
a global pandemic you think you know
what the [ __ ] a power womb versus power
bomb is what is a power bomb body slam
is that a body slam power bomb somebody
i'm going power bomb because it sounds
pretty cool because if somebody's like
hey you can't get into this nightclub
you're like [ __ ] i'll powerbomb you and
they're like you mean power womb and
you're like yes i do and then i just
fist him in the ass get to the womb
would you rather have your porn search
history shared with your twitter
followers or your parents
i'm going twitter followers twitter's
you know twitter's a great place
twitter's already pornhub junior like i
can't scroll twitter without a girl just
getting anal at like 9am and it's like
look i love you kendra sunderland but
you don't have to retweet every scene
all right i know i know we're getting
the views up and and i'm an avid watcher
big fan but it's it's a hard thing well
it's hard hard you know penis it's hard
to just scroll twitter in public and not
just at least get a gif of like bouncing
titties and be like yeah i'm on a bus
okay i could go to i could go to jail
for this there's a row of kids behind me
why am i on a school bus who knows all
right that's a question for another
answer to the internet but yeah i'm
going twitter followers twitter's
already a horny enough place would you
be better at being the pope or the potus
that's president of the united states i
am assuming i'm gonna go pope that hat
looks [ __ ] fire that [ __ ] right here
what's he got up there
i think he's got orville bill
redenbacher's popcorn in there i'm gonna
go pope because the pope is like you've
already lived a life the youngest age
that you can be a pope at like 74 i
think so you can have your fuckboy
phases you can go through the whole
world doing what you want and then at
like 74 you just kick it off and you're
like what up give me the big hat would
you rather have a perfect bracket but
not make any money or get a hundred
grand perfect bracket like ncaa sports
basketball 100 grand i don't know what
you get with a perfect bracket
uh besides everybody just chants your
name in a buffalo wild wings but i'm
going 100 grand because then you can
just buy the buffalo wild wings and
marry for the waitresses call me the
pope if you could have the perfect body
as long as you never drank or did drugs
again but you could eat whatever you
want would you do it no because then you
got to be the guy at the bar who's just
got six-pack abs and then the waiter's
like oh what do you want you're like let
me just get uh water with lemon in it
and it's just like it's really just it's
just if erectile dysfunction was a
person that's like the energy they give
off just wet blanket
soggy sourdough bread energy but they're
[ __ ] jacked for what what do you need
to be jacked for if you don't want to go
to a bar
you just want to be jacked and work at h
r block what is that what does that do
for anybody would you give up an inch of
penis length for an inch of height i
can't be going negatives dog got
negative dick game i ain't doing that
got negative one down there i can't do
that no i'm i'm i'm six feet allegedly
one time a doctor told me i was five
eleven and three fourths and [ __ ] him i
hope that doctor got fired because that
hurt my feelings because you know what i
had to put on my bumble profile after
that
when you put 51134s for height i just
put [ __ ] so
you stay over at someone's house and
when you wake up you realize you piss in
their bed do you sneak out or you tell
them well look you gotta just tell them
or
better yet here's what you do you sneak
out go to petco get a cat throw the cat
on the bed run away cat piss the bed
boom not me even though i was so drunk i
probably like tried to pee like it was
snow and be like trovers
i'm blaming it on a cat so yeah now i'm
gonna do a hybrid i'm gonna tell him but
in a discreet way okay a cat sorry you
now have a cat for the next 12 years
your life here's mittens would you
rather sleep with a sexy [ __ ] or a
below average regular chick i'm going
sexy [ __ ] dude i had a friend who
slept with a [ __ ] and
he said it was a lot of fun so i want to
be able to now text that guy i haven't
talked like five years and be like dude
we have one more thing in common and
he's like what's that alcoholism and i'm
like
close
we both banged a little person i think
that'd be cool i think it'll be a lot of
fun and also they have small hands so
proportionally things look better you
know
penis size would you rather have your
dick as your nose or your nose as your
dick well i'll tell you what dude i
already got a [ __ ] cockle of a nose
right here all right i'm already rocking
that hebrew hammer on my face i don't
even know like there's no winning on
this right because you have a dick on
your nose
you just get excited or you walk past a
yoga class and all of a sudden you're
just rocked up on fourth street and
everybody's like is this guy good and
you're like it'll go away just just wait
till i walk past the basketball hoops
i don't even know if i answer that
question i'm just going whatever the
[ __ ] that what was it dick on nose nose
on dick who cares flip a coin
nose on dick it doesn't matter we're all
wearing mass all of 2020 anyways it
didn't really matter that'd be very
funny though coming out of a pandemic
nobody has a mask on anymore you've got
to take yours off you just got a dung
and a half and you're like wow what's
going on guys huh cynthia
yeah you got to cover up a little bit
he'll keep doing this all right there
you go turtleneck nice would you rather
every porn you watch for the rest of
your life have music or be in a foreign
language foreign language oh my god i
hate when porn is music it's always like
some shitty edm dj who's trying to make
it so he like lines up the [ __ ] shot with
the bass drop he's like
drop the load the last thing i want my
neighbors to think is that not only am i
watching porn at 2 30 p.m but i'm
watching dubstep with it just to help
get pumped up would you rather everyone
in your girlfriend's office want to [ __ ]
her or
nobody want to [ __ ] her
here's the thing man my girlfriend's in
finance so
it's already happening everybody in
finance is just horny like stock socks
sucks tip tip tips stock
tits i think she might be the only girl
that works there if you work in finance
you get horny looking at a keurig
machine if you look at it long enough
like just not great people everybody's
on a cocaine bender i mean they'll [ __ ]
a doorknob if they have to i've seen it
happen if you had one free throw and if
you make it you get a million dollars or
if you miss you never get to text again
would you shoot it
yes i hate communication anyways because
then if i miss i can't text again good
i'll be that [ __ ] who only sends
voice memos like i'm [ __ ] jason
bourne are you guys ready to go to
buffalo wild wings tonight at seven i'll
be in the black mazda miata
sounds fun plus if i make it which also
free throws that's where i think an
unathletic jewish kid like myself will
strive there's absolutely zero defense
and i get to take as much time as i want
to line up with a hoop that's amazing i
mean you put one person on me and i'm
shooting three pointers that's where we
strive as unathletic white people like
myself
free throws and three-pointers and
whatever the [ __ ] brian scalabrine does
shut up brian scalabrine but i'm taking
that shot dude
and then if i miss i'm just sending uh
snapchats to everybody like i'm texting
like what up sorry i gave you chlamydia
jokes
is it courtney my bad mary [ __ ] kill
britney spears amanda bynes lindsay
lohan i mean this is just an eight ball
of cocaine of a question and a half
right here uh i'm gonna marry britney we
need to free brittany i'm gonna save her
you know here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna [ __ ] amanda bynes and lindsay
lohan i'm sorry you're great but i gotta
kill you because you have red hair i
have red hair if we reprocrate
people don't want more gingers in the
world you just can't date a girl when
you're like biggest enemy between the
both of you guys is sunblock you know
that's uh
you could break into our house so easy
you just rob us with spf 50 coppertone
freeze and i'm like [ __ ] can i borrow
that actually
so
that's me that's the internet go comment
shitty stuff in the comments like you
always do i'm like when he said this
wasn't shut up
i just answered the internet peace and
go check out my part one sunday august
29th it's the problem child jake paul
versus the former ufc champion tyron
woodley live if you want tickets to be
in the building go to
rocketmortgagefieldhouse.com
and if you're going to watch it from the
comfort of your own home go to
showtime.com ppv to order your fight
today all right special thanks to trevor
wallace for doing this week's episode of
answer the internet make sure you drop a
comment below for any other comedians or
internet personalities that you want to
see make sure you click to subscribe as
well as turn on the notifications with
clicking the bell i like to post and
share i do a lot good stuff too